listen carefully
watch learn mortal kombat has begun
there's a war coming we need to fight
before it's too late
mortal kombat has started as this very
simple 8-bit fighting game
that was revolutionary at the time i
liked the idea that we could bring
these characters to a level that hadn't
really been seen before
in the games the fighting is brutal
fight
and so you've got to hire these people
that have that ability excellent
the fight scene's so epic
it's mind-blowing what they do really
the fatalities are sickeningly violent
flawless victory but we all knew that we
needed to cast some
really amazing talented people to make
it feel real
lewis tan's an incredible athlete
incredible fighter
a guy worked so hard was just
unbelievable
he just did not stop
i come from a fighting background real
martial arts to me is very similar to
acting because it's all about expression
there's so much fighting in this movie
that a lot of times after
shooting one fight
we need to practice for some other fight
that's gonna take place because we just
don't have
enough time
i knew joe was going to be sub-zero from
day one
joe's got that pure athleticism
i made the mistake of watching the raid
a couple nights before we fought i go i
gotta fight this dude
i gotta fight i gotta fight that dude
joe was faster than everyone joe was too
fast
joe was so fast i had to ask him to slow
it down for the camera it was like two
guys
that's ever happened to joe taslim and
bruce lee
a fight scene and a drama scene they are
the same
in a drama you have the lines but in a
fight
just the agony struggle the pain those
are our lines
you cast for what's in their brain what
they've learned over the years
especially with something like martial
arts
it's impossible to bring someone up to
his level
quickly that's just not going to happen
the same goes for hiroyuki sonata they
both have a very similar set of
qualities in that they have a presence
they have a look about them
we try to make a contrast between
sub-zero and scorpio a little
mixture between game and authentic
japanese style
watching those two on set was one of the
great privileges i'll ever have in my
life
[Music]
you